what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with banner of war alpha yes we
are now the reason why it's called alpha
instead of part one is because the
banner of war is an event but it's a
crossover event so unlike stories like
uh civil war where you have civil war
part one part two part three part four
so on and so forth instead banner of war
is a crossover between the thor and the
hulk comics so you get banner of war
alpha and then you go into a thor comic
then a hulk comic and a thor comic back
and forth until the story concludes with
a banner of war omega i think is what it
is um so here's one of the things that i
would suggest is we're going to include
this and and probably give it its own
playlist where we're going to combine
the thor and the hulk stories together
and then that way you can literally just
keep up so it makes things easier so you
don't have to jump between the hulk
playlist and the thor playlist so you'll
find a link to that down in the
description but what this does is it
initially gives us a bit of a recap
involving these characters uh which we
can cover here it can't necessarily hurt
for those of you guys who for whatever
reason don't want to see the other other
stories themselves but the the overall
gist of this is that um in effect thor
had become the new king of asgard and it
had been building that for quite some
time uh really following the the war of
realms and that kind of stuff the fact
that the throne had been handed over to
thor by odin but then somewhere along
the line galactus had shown up talking
about the end of times which led to the
black winter storyline where ultimately
galactus was a herald of the black
winter that the black winter itself
traveled around the multiverse consuming
whole universes and galactus was
originally tasked with traveling around
the multiverse and finding universes for
the black winter to consume only for
galactus to defect now that was a huge
change to the galactus mythos to his
origin story and all that stuff we won't
really know if that's going to stick
long term uh only time will tell but
then that went into the story of
essentially donald blake the idea that
donald blake being the alternate
personality of thor had just kind of
been chained in this alternate reality
and things have kind of gone nuts and
then ultimately he was defeated but the
bigger takeaway from this is really the
the visions that thor was getting and
which ultimately donnie cape seems to be
building up to and him fighting his own
hammer the visions he was getting was
basically thanos with the destroyer
armor mjolnir which was covered in the
infinity stones which just sounds
daunting as hell and leading like an
army of zombies essentially and then of
course thor having to fight his own
hammer mjolnir so that was kind of his
story arc with banner it's a little more
straightforward but also a little more
mysterious that somehow in el paso 17
people died we know by virtue of the
ending of the last story that's probably
due to the titan hulk but we don't
necessarily know for sure we're still
waiting on an answer for that all we
know is that banner being chased down by
the avengers just ended up escaping to
an alternate reality and his story
unfolded there but the reality here is
that these two paths are finally
crossing with each other now the fights
between thor and hulk are legendary i
mean it's one of those hallmarks of
marvel comics and the thor and the hulk
mythos right that whenever any kind of a
news story is told involving one or both
of them it's only a matter of time
before they fight it's like every time
dc reboots batman and superman always
end up fighting somewhere along the line
uh so it's just one of those cool things
that usually is just kind of a mythos of
both of them whenever you're talking
about a new iteration of a character
that's when you usually see that so thor
achieving a new level of power hulk
achieving a new level of power it's
really marvel kind of got their finger
on the pulse of the fan base who want to
know how would thor or hulk be able to
handle the new power of the other person
and so what you end up getting here is
of course the fight breaking out between
the two again kind of in this alternate
dimension because remember banners sort
of flying through the multiverse at the
moment uh and they end up on a place
called secret right this alternate
reality where which is basically
composed of cartoons and what we're told
is that it smells of cotton candy and
puppy paws and death that basically the
way this works
[Laughter]
donnie kate's this guy's got a twisted
sense of humor the way this works in
this beautiful adorable little cartoon
town that looks a lot like adventure
time uh that he says like a it's a
wretched planet filled with
disease-plagued war-mongering cannibals
that devour the eyes of their young to
appease their all-knowing pain god i
mean that's pretty brutal man not even
gonna lie
[Laughter]
that's pretty intense but one thing to
know and this is one of the things that
i love the way that donnie kate's
handles this because it's not a
traditional fight between thor and
banner i mean it is like they are
fighting but the whole thing about this
is remember the spirit of odin is inside
mjolnir now and so it has conversations
with thor not only that that banner kind
of seems to have his own sort of odin
thor dichotomy going on between himself
and like betty ross now betty ross seems
to be the mental personification of the
titan hulk that seems to be the case we
don't know for sure but there's not
really any indication to indicate
otherwise but the two of them are just
kind of having conversations with
themselves and it sort of reaches this
point where it's like like banners like
leave me alone betty ross and and thor's
like that's final you know and it's like
they kind of look at each other for a
second and it's like who are you talking
to and thor is like well who are you
talking to and then hulk's like uh uh
hulk smash like they just start
attacking each other again
[Laughter]
right this whole cartoon town is just
being torn to pieces this the whole
place is being just absolutely wrecked
and it gets kind of nuts because at that
point uh that's when thor literally
tells sif take us anywhere anywhere
where people won't get hurt in the
middle of this fight right it doesn't
matter where and so ultimately they're
transported to the black hand of god now
if you guys recall from the last thor
story that we did the black hand of god
is just this giant celestial hand that
houses what is in effect uh a tournament
system right like some of the greatest
battles that have ever taken place
across the universe happen in this this
gladiatorial ring so it quite literally
is the best place for the two of them to
fight and it's to a degree reminiscent
of planet hulk so it's nice little
callbacks there of course donnie kate's
has a little fun with it as well where
he turns it in almost kind of a video
game thing right where it's like hulk
versus thor who's going to win round one
fight you know and like that kind of a
thing that's cool i definitely dig that
right it would have been cooler if it
felt more like tekken than anything else
but again this is a pretty brutal and
knocked down fight between the two now
one of the things that thor iterates
here is that with everything that's gone
on he just has this hankering to hit
something and that's kind of in the
nature of thor that whenever things
become highly stressful thor's response
is to just want to fight something and
as a warrior it makes sense right that's
how you deal with your stresses is like
you fight things and who better to fight
them than the incredible hulk because
the hulk can take it the other part of
this though and this is something that
doesn't need to be reiterated is that
because of the 17 people who were killed
in el paso that were still a little
murky on the details about that thor of
course wants to ultimately bring the
hulk in but why not release some stress
and smack him around a little bit you
know while you're while you're in the
process of doing that
and so what you end up having this is
one of the coolest changes that goes on
here and it's something that i don't
think we've seen since the peter david
run by the peter david days of uh of the
incredible hulk that when the incredible
hulk is pinned down by mjolnir the
incredible hull can't get past it right
remember like the hammer cannot be
lifted except by those who are
essentially worthy and that's where thor
kind of gets a little caught up with
himself and starts talking to banner and
he's like i'm literally going to take
you in and so ultimately banner ends up
kind of going into manual remember
banner psyche is the one that's
essentially controlling the body of the
incredible hulk and the incredible whole
persona itself is in the engine room
essentially fighting just these this
constant onslaught of beings which
basically amps up the incredible hulk's
anger or brings the incredible hulk down
and so what banner ends up doing here is
one amping amping everything up to level
eight which as you guys know from our
previous coverage the higher the level
the more extreme the threat the angrier
the whole gets the more powerful he
becomes at the same time what he also
does is by going in manual he's the one
that fights so it's almost like those
jaegers from pacific rim which is really
cool um and that's what he's kind of
warned look like you really shouldn't do
this like we don't know what effect this
is going to have in this situation that
the incredible hulk has fought thor
before you've never fought the you never
fought thor yourself banner and so in
essence i would go as far as to say
because of the different levels that
we've seen this is bruce banner and the
body of the hulk most likely at world
breaker hulk levels fighting thor and
it's kind of nuts because it's basically
the mind and the intelligence of banner
now one of the big issue here is because
of the fact that in years past whenever
the incredible hulk manifested banner
wouldn't necessarily know what was going
on between the two he doesn't have a
full recollection of their historical
accounts rather historical fights and so
because those memories are in the mind
of hulk those memories are pumped into
banner and what it does is it gives him
the advantage of having his own
intelligence along with the wisdom that
comes with knowing how it is that thor
and hulk have fought over the years
because how thor fights the hulk is
different from how thor fights anybody
else right if a fight breaks out between
thor and captain america one thor's not
going to go to the same length of
the same degree of strength and rage as
he would fighting hulk but his fighting
style would also be different as well
because captain america can't
necessarily take the same kind of
punishment that hulk can take but
captain america is also a more
prodigious fighter so how the two of
them interact would be different from
how thor interacts with hulk so having
all those memories and all that
experience under his belt gives banner
this edge in the sense that like he's
like okay if i can't lift mjolnir then
i'll just power through it literally
pushes himself up and mjolnir goes
through him guts and everything just
stuck to the ground and starts to heal
himself and like one of the coolest
moments like he's drawn as like just
this huge shadowy threat he's like thor
pick up your hammer and thor's like i
and like the two of them get into a
fight because the reality here is is
kind of what they both want right like
they're literally both coming from a
place where like they just been through
a lot of crap and they're just looking
for something to hit and they're there
in a gladiatorial ring and they just
start smashing and fighting into each
other now one of the cool things to also
know is that the hammer of thor right
odin's spirit is kind of feeding
information to thor as this fight goes
on and it's kind of like look i've got a
lot of experience you need to let me get
involved in this thor is a little
stubborn in the sense that he's like no
i don't want to like i want to just
punch some things for a little while
kind of do my thing but we'll deal with
that later what ends up happening though
is the hammer kind of with a life of its
own basically just flies up into the sky
right and then comes crashing down onto
uh onto banner and the whole thing about
this is it's cool because it kind of
incapacitates hulk for a moment or two
and thor of course grabs the upper hand
uses it and the two of them start
fighting again now one thing to know
this whole fight is being observed by
all these people in this gladiatorial
ring and it's probably the single
greatest fight they've ever witnessed
right they're just kind of like okay
like this fight is insane it's nuts the
bigger problem here though is despite
how capable thor is and despite having
mjolnir because of the fact that he's
fighting bruce banner he's fighting the
incredible hulk with the mind and
intelligence of banner and the strength
of the hulk he's basically outclassed
here and if this fight keeps going on
long enough there's no way thor is going
to win because yes thor's a very capable
fighter he's not really on the same
level of intelligence as banner he's
smart enough to be able to adapt battle
strategy you just never really see him
do it all that often but when you do see
banner adapt battle strategy and
essentially use his intelligence on that
particular task oh he's a force to be
reckoned with it's really really cool
and so ultimately in this moment that's
when odin really kind of tells tells
thor look you cannot hold on to this
battle long term not only that when i
struck when i struck banner right when i
struck the hulk it wasn't like in years
past where we've dealt with him before
there's something else here right he's
not really possessed it's more like he's
haunted but there's more in there than
just bruce banner something else is
going on here you have to let me be
involved right i have an idea and so
ultimately thor's like okay and thor
relinquishes right throws the hammer at
banner and the hammer literally just
like crashes into banner's face and when
that happens it allows the spirit of
odin to leave the hammer and enter into
the mind of bruce banner and as soon as
he appears he was like bruce banner i
would have words with thee for the first
time that i'm aware of and recorded
history and marvel comics odin has
invaded the mind of the incredible hulk
and is now challenging bruce banner i'm
excited to see where this goes man i'm
curious right i think i think thor
number 25 comes out next week i think
it's a weekly series uh so we're gonna
go we're like we're gonna do this as it
comes out we're gonna cover this as it
goes through but i'm excited this looks
like it's gonna be great but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section and i
will catch you all later
peace